Ethan himself. Ethan. Ethan himself. Bingo. Bango.
>> I won't believe for a second that Pisco doesn't get
high for these evening streams. Okay.
[laughter]
Exactly.
Bingo. Oh, bango. I have more money than you. You criticize me.
Now dance, twirl in circles, and say you're a little piggy, and
I'll let you go. Okay? Dance and say you're a little piggy. And
then you can go home. You can go back to your house. Otherwise,
I take your house. Bingo. Bango. Let's go.
>> Okay. Apparently, um, we had Stale hop on Pisco stream
to argue about, you know, change your mind on this. Or if you
do, >> um, I I
challenges you have aren't like stupid, but >> Oh, he's
doing comments again. >> He had Stale on. Stale hopped
on to
>> Let's see. Let's see what it looks like.
>> All right. Yeah, I got some some arguments. Um, I'll
just get right into it. So, >> let's check it out. >> I
think that Ethan is a metaphorical gay hat hacker. He has, you
know, defaced a
>> This is already totally
Oh man, I'm going to
after stream I feel like I'm going to try to put something together
on this. >> That has a bug that is in all websites. Therefore,
bringing attention to it. How this relates to copyright law is
I think that most React content is illegal. Uh it's all over
the internet. It's ubiquitous and people think they're safe,
but they're not. One person or one company could do exactly what
Ethan did, like a like a super evil Ethan and just sue a,000
10,000 people at once and, you know, get cause hundreds of millions
of dollars in damages. And the only way to stop this is to put
fear in people's hearts. You got to ruin some lives, crack some
heads, uh do some lawsuits. And so counter counterintuitively
by enforcing it more uh you have
you know re make made people realize that none of this is safe
and you know hopefully stop it. >> I think
>> okay so transparently that's totally because Ethan has
said that's the opposite of what he wants to do. He he literally
said I'm not going after XQC or Asold because I don't want to
go after anybody who does this in good faith who's like a normal
actor. So you'd have to agree from the very beginning that Pisco
is automatically correct in in Stale's worldview. Stale just
came on and said, "I totally agree with you, Pisco." under the
pretense of arguing. He came on and said, "I totally agree with
you, Pisco. Actually, um, just so you know, I think Ethan's like
totally disingenuous and he's actually over this entire community
like immediately right off the bat." >> Mrs. Cope, and
I'll tell you why. I appreciate the attempted argument and I
and I understand what you're saying. I think I do.
It's like it's 40 chests to make sure that unethical reactors
like people who do full reactions like XQC and Asmin Gold have
to change their ways now, right? Because obviously those same
reactions based on the Denim's lawsuit are equally susceptible.
>> Everyone already knew that.
>> They know that. They know that. But they're not stopping.
Like so >> and and do you think they're going to stop after
this lawsuit? No.
Maybe not this one, but like I don't know, maybe like a 10x Ethan.
Like if if somebody just started >> Yeah. What might have
done that perhaps is if Ethan went after
broader groups of people than just the people who he's enemies
with. Everyone, no one is fearful, right, of reacting to Ethan
content if they're glazing him. You agree with that, don't you?
>> Uh, yeah. Well, they're not.
>> This is the entire argument. You're just chilling criticism
because nobody is going to report people who react to their content
favorably unless it's like XQC fully re redoing like the Nexo
videos or something, right? But nobody's going to just nobody's
going to sue people who react to content in full who are like
super nice to them if it's like political content, let's say.
But for all political content now,
if somebody reacts to your video in full, you absolutely
could go register that video with the Library of Congress and
sue them.
And Ethan has opened Pandora's box on this. And now everybody
knows. And now everything's man. Everything's Well, I don't know
if everything's but what nothing prevents anyone from doing this
in the future. And they're obviously only going to do it to people
who piss them off.
Obviously, it's not going to become a thing overnight. You're
never gonna do it to people who are nice. >> That guy.
>> Yeah. And and no one's afraid that this is going to
this isn't going to cause people to stop doing movie streams,
>> I mean, >> has anyone been tal Have you seen any
discourse like, "Oh, wow." Like, we really shouldn't be doing
these react streams anymore. This is dangerous because Ethan
did it. Ethan, in fact, says he specifically doesn't want to
do that. He doesn't want to chill the React community. He says
that in his video. So if he doesn't want to chill the react community,
even though most of I agree with you, a lot of the reactions,
the meta is very very illegal and infringement um based on what
I I think are would be,
you know, just a balanced application of the fairies principles.
He in his video goes so far as to say, I don't want to kill people
like Asmin Gold and XQC.
>> He he did say that, but but he also said something like
um you know, he set the line for what's allowed. He also wants
to set the line for what's disallowed. I forget the exact phrasing.
So, so, >> but he can't do that. He literally can't do
that. He literally can't achieve the goal he stated. >> He's
saying, "I don't want to chill it." He's talking about the uh
the safe React content, not the very bad stuff that's >> Yeah.
But the very bad stuff that's ubiquitous isn't stated intentional
siphoning. The very bad stuff that's
>> Yeah. Yeah. Pisco's like, "The really bad stuff is when
you when you do what Caseyron did or what what uh Denims did,
and then you say, "Uh, this guy, I want to take all of his views."
Even if that didn't happen, just that's what Stale believes,
right? The the thing that's bad is when you say this guy, I want
to take all his views.
That's that's the unethical part that he wants to cut out. Leave
alone the fact that he could never set a precedent for that.
Is the entire meta, right? It it would be like saying,
>> um, this isn't the issue, Pumpern Nickel. This is not
the issue at all. If Ethan just didn't like these people and
based on copyright grounds, he just sued them. Okay, that would
be gay. That would be gay. But he could be honest about it and
he would get the criticism the like basically what what the issue
is for everyone right now is they go this guy's just suing people
to silence criticism obviously transparently and a bunch of people
come OUT AND GO NO THAT'S NOT TRUE DON'T SAY THAT you can't criticize
him like that don't say that
and those people are all loser freaks okay but that's what we're
dealing with that's who I don't like right don't say he's just
a fragile who's only suing
but he is he's a totally fragile [__] who's just
suing critics
there there is nothing else there. He has the right to sue those
critics. But with Denims, he's actually jeopardizing all the
things he said he wasn't. So there's a second lie there, which
is, "Oh, I'm doing this to protect React content from people."
No, you're not. You're risking everything for everyone. The exact
people you said you didn't want to risk, you're risking by suing
Denims. And again, you're doing this because you are a fragile
[__] Okay? So it's the audience who won't admit that
he is a fragile [__] who's only suing people to silence
criticism. And it's him saying he's doing it for altruistic reasons,
which he is not. He's obviously not. Right.
And as long as you admit that he's a fragile [__]
in both cases, and neither of those copes are relevant or true,
and that he should get the criticism, the public criticism of
somebody who only sues people to silence his critics, right?
Because he's a whiny [__] who can't actually get
his critics to shut up or make fun of them in the marketplace
of ideas, the streaming space, right? the commentary space where
he has made a consistent living out of mocking and deriding people,
right? And now people have mocked and derided him and he has
sued them. He is a total hypocrite. He is totally spineless.
He is a total.
And if as long as you can admit all of those things, then oh,
you and I have no issue, my friend.
Cuz every single [__] has their rights under the
law. And if they want to be a under the law with their legal
rights, they can do so. Just don't expect any respect from any
of these communities. Or at least anybody who does show you respect
based on these actions is a loser, too. Almost as big a loser.
Maybe a bigger loser for just looking the other way because they
think they can get some clout from you. [__] that.
I This is what it sounds like to me.
>> People are saying he's suing them just for criticism
is kind of wild. Okay, Pumpern Nickel, do you want to hop in
the Discord? We can have this conversation. Just hop in the Discord
with me. Okay. I'm By the way, I've had three hours of sleep
the past like 4 days. I am so mentally [__] fried.
So, might be some uh you might have to be slow. We might have
to slow down, but let's talk. Hop in the Discord.
I'm high and drunkish, but okay, that's fine.
We can chat. We can chat. Here, give me a second. I'm going to
hit play on this. I'm going to use the bathroom real quick, and
I'm guessing you'll be in the waiting room by the time I get
back. Can >> you tell me why it's different?
Um, I there's a horrible meta, horrible, horrific meta
of this reaction streams
happening on
And so, we just need to go so hard on people who react in this
obviously infringing way that siphons revenue on Wednesdays.
But everyone who's doing that every other day, you know, that's
fine. I'm not I don't want to chill that. I only want to chill
it for
You understand? Like it it it's you're pointing at a problem
and the problem is
uh you know the central nucleus of the problem is
stuff that Ethan doesn't want to chill. The central nucleus of
the problem is infringement.
It a it's not transformative. It's definitely like a market substitute.
It's definitely you know a total amount of use and substantiality.
And the nature of the works are often artistic. Like on every
factor, most of the this React meta fails miserably. And the
legal analysis doesn't turn on the thing that people claim it
does. So it really doesn't, you know, it's so arbitrary. Yeah.
This is a distinction perhaps between what they did and what
other people did that would justify someone suing another person.
>> Okay. Is Pumpern Nickel in the waiting room? I don't
see him in the waiting room. We'll see if he
because they don't like them and because they just they think
that that is indicates like um a malignant heart perhaps. But
it doesn't
justify the explanation that this is to help the React community
cuz crucially the React community's problem isn't in in you know
intentional stated malice. The React community's problem is rampant
Oh, should I start arguing with Pumpernnickel even before he
gets in the waiting room? Okay, this whole thing you say right
here, I think people who are saying he's suing them just for
criticism is kind of wild. I don't buy his stance on react content.
I personally would not steal content from a fragile [__]
but that's just me. Okay, so the way Denim stole content is the
same way everybody stole content from Ethan, right?
That's not what he's suing her for. Because there are people
who were far more harmful, who were far more egregious in their
conduct with regards to stealing his content, who have not reacted
substantially, who have taken his thumbnail, who have done every
single thing that he had previously laid out as as his criteria
for siphoning views, right? And he has he has foregone all of
those actual criteria, those legitimate criteria. And now he
says, "Well, she said that she was happy that they took my views,
so this stupid [__] has to die." I like, okay, um,
that doesn't make any sense cuz you actually know for a fact
that XQC is siphoning your views, you believe that 100% that
he has the intent to siphon your views, but you haven't sued
him. So, you're arguing your argument is that the fact that she
said she wanted to punch you in the face, is worse than XQC actually
punching you in the face. So, XQC barely reacts. He just says,
"I'm just sitting here learning." And then he uploads the video
in full. All right? And you don't sue him. Yu Denims who did
a a more than doubling of the video's length in terms of her
reaction. And at the very end she goes, "Ah, this guy. Yeah,
this guy. If you liked watching that video without his uh like
without giving him a view, send me a like. Send me a primer.
Let's
So, she wasn't even looking to set up a market replacement. She
was doing something that pretty much nobody would want to watch
who's actually an Ethan fan, right? Nobody wants to watch Denim's
reaction in full. It's it's going to be garbage, right? Her voice
is like nails on a chalkboard.
So, she didn't create a market replacement. I don't believe she
created a market replacement. Her intent to create a market replacement.
I don't even think you can fully establish that.
But even if you could, her intent to create the market replacement
or her spoken intent um sorry, actually even on even on intent,
you believe XQC intends to create a market replacement, too.
So, here's both of them with the intent to create a market replacement
that you say is important. But what's the actual differentiating
factor? the fact that she said she might intend. The fact that
I can argue she said she intends to
leave. I don't give a about whether or not she actually intends
to or if she did. Don't care about either of those. It's just
the fact that she said she might want to.
So, in essence, the argument is uh actually it's worse for you
to say you're going to punch me in the face than actually punching
me in the face. Because there's no doubt that in terms of actual
harm, actual siphoning of views, XQC's YouTube video is far worse
for Ethan than Denim's react.
It's obviously true,
>> which isn't defined by intentional state malicinating
room yet. >> Yep. Yeah. So, so I I recognize that point.
Uh here's where I disagree and why I think the distinction is
>> Um what's important is not necessarily just that what
you're doing is illegal. It it's also like if you're doing something
that would people off and is also illegal that >> um actually
the distinction is Ethan just wants to chill criticism. That's
the distinction. Like his critics are the people who would be
under threat of getting sued but if you're like really nice and
you glaze them then you're not at threat of getting sued at all.
>> That's worse even though it doesn't make sense. So with
your Wednesday example, >> imagine there was a secret anti-Wednesday
company or something. um you know maybe it would make sense to
make an example about somebody so that the Super Evil Wednesday
company doesn't go after everybody.
>> yeah, but that's what's happening here because because
do you really think that Disney and Sony are going a that people
are there's this rampid problem of intentional state of malice
such that it would even be relevant to bring it up? Yeah, I I
understand it's conceivable that intentional state of malice
might pick off
uh hold on there was another thing here. When did Metal Oh, Metal
was saying this way earlier. The Casey Tron was definitely guilty
of the reaction. Oh, here it is. Knowing a 4-hour react of a
dumb stoner girl coughing over the video is a market substitute,
but she also didn't transform at all. That's the problem. So,
while she might not have created a market sub substitute, she's
like not transforming at all. So, under a different pillar, she
like fails
like like yeah I would say probably she didn't really create
a market substitute. She also didn't really do any harm but she
like basically just without doing any effort whatsoever without
any transformation kind of reuploaded the content in full kind
of rereamed the content in full as she does quite often certain
entities or groups more but to the extent that it's not appearing
it's not being actualized there's no widescale
uh you know it's kind of funny and stupid that they would say
things that could be construed that way. Uh, for sure. I mean,
>> I'm gonna have such a hard time arguing right now. I
can feel my brain is like moving sludge, >> but it's not
this rampant issue that Ethan needs to resolve. And so, so the
the notion that he's resolving it to preempt against Sony and
Disney for a problem that isn't occurring, namely the problem
of infringement specifically
um, intentional stated malice.
That is what is strikes me as implausible because you don't really
think that you're going to prevent Sony and Disney from having
devastating precedent lawsuits if you don't think that this is
a very common occurrence, right? And especially when he couldn't
have predicted that the creators for whom he was setting a trap,
his words, not mine, would have made those statements. So his
plan uh abio at the initial part of it wasn't an intentional
state of malice. So why was he registering his copyright? Because
he predicted infringement, not intentional state of mal. >> Oh,
there's another really key piece here. There's another really
key piece for the Denim's case that makes it far more egregious.
It's that he knew. He knew after Denim's reaction, okay, he knew
that she actually reacted substantially and he needed something
else. And so what did he do? He went and reviewed her Twitch
stream and realized she cherry reacted to some of the stream
that was announcing
the video, right? That was leading into the video. She cherry
reacted to part of that.
Oh my god, let's go. And he registered way after the fact his
stream from that day.
So, not only that, like you couldn't even he knew he wanted to
get her on the non-transformative element, so he registered his
stream instead of the content nuke. And that is maybe where he
could get her on some non-transformative react and maybe like
set a precedent against like chair reacting to certain things
possibly.
But like that's obviously not what he set this whole thing up
to be, right? Nobody really cares about a live streamer sniping
another streamer and walking away for a second. Nobody really
thinks that you should be paying like massive statutory penalties
for that. Nobody really agrees with that at all. Okay. But that's
that's what he actually did. It's such it's so disingenuous
the way he set this up. It's so gross.
>> he decided he decided the people he was going after
decided his targets for this before he even put the video out.
>> Benjamin, right? Like you understand that, right? When
he registered his copyright to get statutory fees, he couldn't
have known that these people would make those statements. And
so it wasn't an intentional state of malice. So why was he registering
his copyright? Because he predicted infringement, not intentional
stated malice over kick infringement, right? like you understand
that right when he he registered his copyright to get statutory
fees he couldn't have known that these people would make those
statements and so it strains cajuli I think that was what's motivating
him is to protect from devastating precedent on a factor that
when he started this whole the shebang he wouldn't have known
about in advance and uh that isn't relevant to the legal analysis
and that isn't common such that we would need to prevent
reactors from establishing that because it doesn't occur
it's so preposterous
So um let me explain what the discriminating factor is. So technically
it's not stated malice. Technically the discriminating factor
is all things that would therefore make it more likely that somebody
would sue. So uh what I mean by that is the reason why uh society
has not collapsed with most of React content is people follow
a unstated social contract. There's things that they do, there's
things that they don't do. you know, you give credit to the author,
even though g giving credit to the author does not protect you
at all legally. Um, the only thing it does is you're you're being
nice to the person so that they don't sue you. How this applies
to, you know, Sony and Disney? Well, the answer would be maybe
not stated malice, but it would be something else, right? like
uh uh you know, don't infringe on uh a movie that is uh in theaters
right now, but uh you know what, you might actually be okay if
it's a movie from 10 years ago, even though technically both
are equally illegal. You know, the movie from yesterday versus
the movie from 10 years ago. You should follow the social contract
of what is more likely to, you know, piss people off and then
like follow that. And and I think >> Yeah. Oh, if if if
he if if he had
>> dude I I feel like I'm going to go write a tweet after
this, okay? It's going to be something along these lines. It's
going to be this Pandora's box concept and I'm going to actually
at Asminold and say, "Hey everybody, just so you know, here's
what you can do. If you have had a negative reaction from Asminold,
if you hate Asmin Gold right now, what you can do is you have
90 days to register a video of yours that he watched in full
with the Library of Congress, okay? and you will be entitled
to sue him for copyright infringement.
You will have the same or a better chance of getting a win. Oh,
same with XQC. You'll have the same or a better chance of winning
than Ethan Klein does. Okay. Against Denims,
you can go sue them. You can go do this now, but only if you
have money. Well, you don't have to have that much money.
No. Hey, I bet you I bet you you could crowdfund it. Bet you
you could crowdund it really easily. Hey, I just want to [__]
over Asmin Gold. Actually, you guys want to goofund me my my
[__] over Asminold fee?
I don't think you want that heat. I'm Listen, maybe I don't actually
say Sue Asminold, okay? But that would be like the example. I
I am going to tweet about the Pandora's box thing, but literally
now all criticism is broken. All criticism in full video reacts
you can no longer do. You absolutely can't. You will have to
get clips. You'll have to react to clips, right? You'll have
to find the things you need that you need to go and react to.
It will increase the burden of of all criticism on the internet
significantly. Maybe you argue that's a good consequence. I'm
sure some people would argue that's a good consequence, right?
But it totally changes things. Totally changes everything as
gold does. Totally changes everything XQC does. Any of their
glaze videos, those have to completely change, right? Dude, can
you imagine how this is going to look in the hands of Techone,
a totally rich, totally spineless to loser. Can you imagine?
And he just watched how everybody, oh yeah, you're so cool, Ethan.
You you totally destroyed Casey.
Holy. Can you imagine? Every single petty rich loser streamer,
loser video creator who exists is now going to wield this tool
with with total like they have total say over whether they [__]
you now,
right? And that's Tee's favorite place to be. Doesn't need consent
to totally somebody. Yeah, that's Tech's favorite spot. Let's
go.
cited one of those um triggering
aspects. So basically what you're suggesting is like so for example
like a UFC fight reaction going to be more problematic present
>> he didn't actually win and set a precedent in that way
I'm not wait what do you think I'm she's a diesor you understand
I'm not talking about a president right now the president he
not a legal precedent the president he said is informing everybody
that you can after the fact ipso facto okay register your copyright
for people who have reacted badly to stuff you understand what
I'm saying right that for the thing that he actually has denims
on where she was was not reacting where she was doing the chair
react. He registered that after she reacted
that you can do this to anybody, this totally disingenuous rat
behavior, right? Anybody who criticizes you and you can get statutory
damages from them. If anybody ever has a chair react where they
walk away, they're reacting to something you did and they walk
away, you can sue them. You can now do that. You just have 90
days from the time of their reaction to go and reg sorry from
the time of you publishing your video to go and register your
video with the Library of Congress and then you could sue them
for statutory damages. And who do we have to thank for publicizing
this method of legal in uh of legal intimidation? Ethan Klein,
Dan Salman, these are the people we have to thank.
They don't even need to. No, they don't. Realistically, you could
go after basically any XQC video tomorrow.
Also, guess what? It's totally going to favor big streamers.
Big streamers will have the money to actually inflict this damage.
Big streamers will also have the money so that you going after
them won't be as profitable or as fruitful and it'll actually
be scary. One, you'll get harassed by their audience, no doubt.
And two, you'll actually have less of a chance of succeeding.
It will cost you more money to go and pursue this.
Don't all these streamers carry personal liability insurance?
Jay, you should get it if you do not have it. Maybe.
Sounds so anti-semitic when you say it like that. No, it doesn't.
I'm not I'm not criticizing them for being I'm criticizing them.
Although I did say Hold on. I did say earlier the whole like
anti-semitic caricature thing, which is unfortunate. Okay. But
I'm not criticizing them for being I'm criticizing them for the
things they've done, right? And just the fact that this has been
introduced is enough to chill criticism. Just the fact that this
has been publicized in such a huge way is enough to start chilling
this criticism. Bro, what about Akos Singh? How do you stop Akos
Singh from going to do this? Akos Singh, massively rich, massively
massively popular before. Okay. How do you not arrest him or
or his wife? How does his wife not uh How do you not How do you
not Oh my god, I'm going to have to go to sleep. I think I read
the word arrest over somewhere here. Okay. How do you not get
sued by Akos or Kash's wife over reactions to her content?
Now, I think luckily most of the people are clipping that stuff,
but anything that's like a full video that you've grabbed the
whole thing and you've reacted to, oh my god, you could be in
trouble.
I actually think this is something that needs to be undone. The
like retroactively registering thing, that's insane to me. You
any anytime you're like trying to apply it to some some piece
of content that was before you registered it, that can't possibly
be true. I wonder if there's precedent on that. Actually, Dan
said that that was possible, but maybe it's not possible. Dan
said that like if you register it after 90 days it was possible,
but I actually don't know.
That can't be possible, right? There's no way. There's no way.
Uh, you know, presumably, although I'll note they flag things
even far after it happens. Um, the night of the big fight, right?
Rereaming it that night. And so there's a norm that could trigger
if you're really digging into the bottom line of the UFC by by
doing this kind of thing that undermines them and annoys
>> But did Denim's chair react to to the full stream? No,
she didn't. It was just a segment.
>> Here's the difference though, right? A there isn't such
a neutral principle that's applied here in the in the the analog
to this. He's fine with the reactions that happen right after
his video. And so to the extent that there's a an analogy to
movies that were just released in the video context, then it
it really um
it is to Ethan's detriment because he's totally fine with people
doing reactions right after he releases video. So it's not establishing
that um that precedent from an actual policy to policy analog.
But beyond that,
what is motivating the rights holders in the context of like
these UFC fights or the movie uh holders when it comes to, you
know, reacting to a movie that's in theaters? What is the primary
motivation of why that would pick off that company
in those context? I'll answer the question. It's because it affects
their money, right? >> Sure. So the kind of reactions
that will negatively
uh annoy will annoy these rights holders are the ones that are
most detrimental to their bottom line. That's what'll pick them
off more. And if that's the standard, >> then if what we
care about is deterring conduct that is going to >> um
uh you know lead potentially to more rights violations, then
surely what you would be going after are the biggest reactors.
Oh, this is another thing. It's like or you could have the the
pretext that like, hey, we have to go after all of these people,
even small ones, because we have to prevent anyone from violating
our copyright. But that isn't the position. Ethan has literally
said, I don't mind if people violate my copyright. I don't mind
people like XQC violating my copyright. That's like totally fine
for me. Just don't be like Denims, the ones who do it the most
to the biggest audience and potentially affect the bottom line
uh more significantly. Um, but putting that aside,
Well, first I want you to respond to that, but also
>> you're not calculating how this could incentivize Sony
and Disney. I don't know why anyone in their right mind would
think if you were able to establish a legal precedent or, I don't
know, a cultural precedent by broadcasting to millions of people
this fair use dispute on videos would lead to less latigiousness
on behalf of rights holders. If anything, I mean, these lawyers
read. >> This is the This is the Pandora's box thing, okay?
This is like It's so [__] over. You've just given
lawyers like a guarantee. Hey, dude. What prevents what prevents
Jimmy McIll from coming along? Hold on. What prevents
what prevents Jimmy McIll from coming along and saying, "Hey,
are you a YouTube creator? Does somebody on YouTube not like
your content? Do they react to your content in full?" Well, give
me a call. I'm Jimmy and give me a call. You may be entitled
to
What prevents that?
on. Wait. Hey, Riyle, can you uh Riyle, can you dial up the Library
of Congress? Hold on a second. Hold on a second. Can we go take
a look at this this channel right here? Hold on. Hold on a sec.
Wait, are they watching like a bunch of my content in full like
very regularly?
Actually, they might not have in the past little while, but they
they do
with almost no transformation while they just play video games.
Oh my god.
Now, here's the thing.
I would never do that cuz I'm not a loser, okay? I'm not I'm
not a loser. If I really have that much problem with a on the
internet, I'll just go call them a on the internet. How about
that? How about when I'm mad at this on the internet who's lying
about me, I'll just go call them a and explain why they're wrong.
Let's go.
It's so simple. Um, you know, they're,
you know, law 360 updates and case updates. You know, they have
litigators. Sony has litigators. Um, Disney has litigators. I
don't know what kind of derangement you would have to have to
think a major blockbuster lawsuit where a rights holder is obtaining
big or even moderate settlements would discourage the litigators
or in-house counsel who work at these firms from seeking out
litigation against um people who use the content. I think that's
absolutely deranged. So those two things, one is um understanding
the actual incentives of the rights holders, money not malice
and two understanding that this public facing lawsuit which is
being broadcast everywhere is obviously uh you know even if it
doesn't result in legal precedent um going to bring attention
to the React meta in a way that could trigger rights holders
to act and there's no good argument that it would do the other
that it would dissuade them from acting. That's crazy.
>> Sure. Yeah. So, so on point one, uh, the discriminating
factor of like the bottom line is technically too specific. It
because the more general one is anything that would piss somebody
off that that is one that the major companies off, but for Ethan
that is not the discriminating factor. And so like it doesn't
make any sense that basically his his factor is don't infringe
on on people that you are >> Yeah. No, no, no, wait, wait.
>> That's that that's exactly it. Oh, his discriminating
factor is criticism.
queen, go off.
Yes,
we hit it. We got there in the end. We got there. >> I
want to stop there cuz I think that's okay. You're saying my
level generality is too specific. And so the precedent that you're
purporting, Ethan, to set is any conduct that would pick off
the rights holder. But people don't need to be put on notice
for that stale because everyone knows that if you off the rights
holder, your liable will be sued. that doesn't need to be told
and so it's not a precedent that needs to be said. If your level
of generality of the president is people now know that they can't
pick off rights holders like okay that was known
>> what but not yet people still do it right and so you
know >> that's my point this isn't going to change like
like to the extent that it's not affecting conduct and yet people
still do it you really think this is going to change people's
conduct no >> it's it's because nobody's getting nuked
yet right so so my my is because like lives aren't being ruined
that's why people think they're safe And then if they didn't
think that, then they would >> So, so you think that what
would be beneficial to set this precedent is for people to have
their react streams nuked, right?
>> On a small scale to prevent the big scale, right? So,
so I'm worried about the super Ethan Quin, the the person who
sets the trap for, you know, a thousand or or like maybe just
like a a movie studio or whatever. Basically, I'm worried about
like >> Wait, but you you understand that this precedent
has now been set like the precedent has been set in a non-legal
way that hey people can do this whenever they want to anybody
who has So basically the precedent has been set that all criticism
is now under threat
right if you are watching the full thing and you're criticizing
a person
you are under threat the big stuff and so nuke it on the small
scale first
>> right so it is to chill
this reaction meta
>> It is it is to chill the very bad stuff but also promote
the good stuff. So it's to force you to
but here reading the good stuff is XQC sitting there and
chat that's true
that's the good stuff and Denim's going well actually Ethan Klein's
lying here because of X Y and Z. That's the bad stuff. Okay.
Okay. The bad stuff is denims in any capacity because skulls,
sword, CPS, and the good stuff is chat. The chat is right. Chat
chat is right. >> Follow the uh
>> What did I call it? The cool >> the social contract
basically, right? So, so promoting the social contract technically
helps the >> Is Asmin Gold and XC upholding the social
contract?
>> Um, it could be worse. I would say >> not according
to Ethan already a solved issue. Not according to Ethan. >> Um
so so uh
>> Ethan himself Ethan Ethan himself. Bingo
I won't believe for a second that Pisco doesn't get high for
these evening streams. Okay.
[laughter]
Exactly.
Bingo. Bango.
>> Let's go.
>> Ethan himself. Ethan. Ethan himself. Bingo. Bango.
>> That's what's going on here. It's PR and it's because
these are easy targets. They don't have a lot of money. Ethan
has power and so he's able to push them around. There's a floor
of litigation expenses to which they're highly sensitive. That's
what's going on here. That's obviously what's going on.
>> If you are unsafe, you should >> I have more money
than you. You criticize me. Now, dance, twirl in circles, and
say you're a little piggy and I'll let you go. Okay.
Dance to say you're a little piggy and then you can go home.
You can go back to your house. Otherwise, I take your house.
Bingo. Bango. Let's go. >> Right. Like, like my point is
like if you are in >> They're making my case for me.
But that helps people like if if you're an idiot. Like so if
you feel safe and you're in danger, you're just an idiot and
somebody's helping you by making you >> right? So in no
sense are you helping the React community are trying to do that.
You are in by your own lights, by your own >> dude. I I
hope you guys understand that
there are no real international laws. They can't really be enforced.
And the United States is helping you understand that by repeatedly
drone striking the floatsome after blowing up a boat. They repeatedly
drone strike that floats him doing a flagrant war crime so-called.
Okay, to show you that you're not actually protected under international
law. That doesn't really exist. That only exists as far as you
can enforce it. And guess who enforces international law? The
country with the international navy. Okay?
So, US doesn't apply. You all need to understand you just all
you need to understand they're doing a good thing for you. Actually,
they're doing a good thing by helping you understand that international
law doesn't apply. You can be drone struck in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean. You can be drone struck in the middle of the
Caribbean. It doesn't apply. It doesn't apply to you. Okay. Own
terminology. You are in like impos. This is what you think is
happening. I don't think he's
suggestions. Get real. That's what I'm saying. It's like, oh,
listen, you're always liable. This was always a concern. You
could always get drone struck in the middle of the Caribbean
multiple times. And now Pete Hexith is just making sure you understand
that he's drone striking a couple small fishing boats so he doesn't
have to drone strike a aircraft carrier from Russia or China.
Okay, that's what he's doing. He's just trying to make people
if it were the case, >> he's imposing a standard that is
going to put the fear of God into
poor people without resources, but it's not going to affect Hassan,
right? only to the extent that Hassan is off Ethan Klein. >> That's
what will be actually chilled is people who are critical of Ethan
reacting to his videos. That will be chilled probably. But it's
specific to Ethan. And the reason that it will be chilled is
because they know Ethan is willing to do these lawsuits. But
it's not because of the principle. It's because it makes people
aware of um you know the lawsuit makes people aware that he's
latigious and he's petty. That's what it makes people aware of.
And that's what
>> uh I think we can all just commit to like tripling down
on Ethan Klein snark. Okay, the the the moral thing to do here
is to triple down on Ethan Klein snark. Okay, I personally didn't
like snarking on Ethan. All right, I wasn't that guy. But I now
feel like it's my moral my moral obligation to snark on Ethan
Klein and to do so in a way that I can be sure passes muster
on fair use. All right, so we're going to have to we're going
to have to clip. We're going to have to do everything we can
to make sure that in in the most most, you know, following a
fair use way possible, we triple down on our H3 snark. Okay?
It's got to happen. It's got to happen. It's the only way. >> This
and we're a small force, okay? There's a lot of disingenuous
losers on the internet who are pretending that this isn't evil,
okay? That this wasn't totally disingenuous, that it wasn't totally
spineless to do. And we're gonna have to make up for all of those
people and the lack of criticism that they'll give, too. It'll
maybe deter, but will it stop anyone else from doing these kinds
of reaction streams? No, it's not broader than that. My whole
point is it's specific to Ethan's circumstances. It's and his
intention is
>> So, so you really think he's following this loss and
he's thinking in in his head this is going to help the re the
broader React community. It's not about money. It's going to
help the broader react community from big rights holders like
Sony and Disney. You think it's conceivably in his mind?
>> Yeah. So, so his his statement from the beginning was
like they people have gone over the line and people need to move
>> before the line because they're going to get nuked.
They're they're they're stepping in front of the train and you
need to not be on.
So, he's gone back. So, we've already done the whole bit about
how oh, obviously XQC's react was far more disingenuous than
Denim's and now he's stepping back to oh actually he's this is
about copyright. This is about where like where the line should
be on copyright. No, it's not. You already admitted it's not.
But this is one of those golems who resets every 30 seconds.
Okay? Their brain resets like a goldfish every single time. All
right? And you have to reexplain the point if they have to reconcile
themselves constantly and there is nothing you can do about it.
These people are subhuman. They don't have souls. Okay? There
is nothing you can do to make them stop. They do not have >> on
the train tracks. And so like yeah, like technically you have
limited somebody by pulling them off of the train tracks, but
that and that's still >> where's the line? Is the line
infringement or is the line upholding the social contract or
the whatever the
>> Okay. But but you but do you cons then therefore do
you acknowledge that XQC is absolutely on Ethan's lights not
upholding the social contract?
>> Um no because I I think that that uh XQC does do good
things, right? So like he has made statements that when people
>> So stale has already conceded this point in this conversation
right he's already conceded this point he has said oh actually
well the the actual thing you should do is not pick off rights
holders and now he's gone back he has reset like the column he
is okay he has reset mentally
[laughter] to 30 to I don't know 20 minutes ago before he conceded
that and he is arguing again that this is about copyright and
and just the fair and ethical use of copyr fair and ethical use,
you know, fair use of um copyrighted materials. That's what it's
about. Again, it's so disgusting. >> We'll reach out to
him for for infringement. He'll like pay the money, right? And
so, like, I think that's that's okay. Like, that there is worse
things than, you know, yeah, I react without permission, but
then I pay you later. I I I think that's okay. >> When
XQC brought that up, Ethan laughed at it.
Ethan ridiculed that argument. Do you remember that debate they
had? Ethan's like, "You want cuz it's an insane argument. Could
you imagine that with any other intellectual property? Hey, I'm
Ford and I'm going to use your new fuel filter that increases
fuel efficiency by 45% to sell enough vehicles to make billions
of dollars and then afterwards I'm going to give you like 300k
and yeah, it's a it's just this thing where I do I use it I violate
your copyright and then I say, "Okay, you're not entitled to
my profits. I'll just pay you a little bit after." Right? It's
insane. If you want to give all the profits back to that that
one video holder and you want to do that um and you feel like
you can do that, okay, maybe maybe XQC will do that, but nobody
else can, right? And XQC built an entire By the way, Ford also
while they do get to um while they do have to pay back, let's
say they even agree to that. They have to pay back those profits.
That's an interest free loan,
right? That's an interest free loan they just took out on research
and development. They they built out a whole thing. They could
have scaled up, made new factories, right? It's crazy. The way
these people argue is insane. >> You have to ask ask permission.
It's like saying that you can borrow my land uh my uh lawn mower
and then saying, "Oh, well, I'll pay you afterwards." The initial
infringement is the property violation at first. So you're bringing
up a point that Ethan ridiculed in the contest of that XTC debate
and saying, "Well,
that point which Ethan obviously rejected in that context is
why Ethan on his lights would think XC is upholding the social
contract when the video starts with him recounting how he was
heavily critical of XQC."
So in no sense is he upholding the social contract. By the way,
this is a concept that you've just now brought up. It's not found
in the video, correct? you you would acknowledge that the social
contract thing this is your vaguely inter vaguely in what's the
best uh you know >> in that he says he doesn't want to
chill good reactions like Asmin Gold and Xuc I would say he's
hinting at something there right I think I think you could argue
that >> I think that he had this idea of a spec very specific
social contract in in mind I think that he had a vague sense
of there is a line and people are going over it and people need
to not go over it and that's that's my definition the That line
is they with me
and now they get the payback. That's the line.
>> Stale's already argu Stale has already lost his argument.
He doesn't remember 15 minutes ago when he lost this
He already lost it. He already admitted the number one the number
one problem is you off the rights holder. That's the most important
thing. He lost it already and he's going back to it and doing
it >> The line is everybody's vulnerable, I >> No,
no, no. You think that wasn't much. So when >> I thought
the line was like ethical reacts. I thought the line was like
transformation.
Dude, >> when he when he plant he says right his own lights
he planted the trap um for the purpose of he says setting a trap.
He didn't uh that it was he knew that he was going to get infringement
and that's why he did it. That's what he says his own lights.
Do you think that when he did that he was he was saying >> I
because I want everyone to know no one's safe or is it they with
me? I was looking for someone specific to go after. What do you
think is more likely?
>> No, I [laughter] I I really do think that this is true.
Like anybody could have set that trap. So like like you're right
it applies to Ethan, but anybody like like the the disincentive
is like why are you picking people off that like you're infringing
on, right? Like you need to be afraid. And like you're you're
right it applies to Ethan, but it could have applied to this
could have been anybody. There could have been a super Ethan.
So, so he sets a trap. Not
the is he saying? Um, actually Ethan Klein's base because
Wait, hold on. Let me think here.
Is this
There's There's some way to turn this into the the rape cage,
isn't there?
Listen, somebody was going to have this lawsuit. Somebody was
going to do it. And now Ethan Klein's like warned everybody.
That woman could have been raped by anybody. So thank god Ethan
Klein raped her first because she was just sitting there waiting
to be raped. Okay. So thank god Ethan Klein, right? Am I wrong?
I feel like it applies. But I also have the worst migraine right
now. Like my brain is falling apart from the lack of sleep. So
possibly not. Possibly I'm just making that up >> knowing
at the time that >> possibly that's like destiny coded
a destiny coded like comparison. I don't know. they're going
to make these statements and we're meant to believe that he set
this trap
with the idea that he's going to get people to make those
>> No. Right. That's imp that's implausible, right?
>> Yes. So, not those specific statements, but maybe like
somebody would do it in his head.
>> Oh, no. Yes. That's that maybe. But that is if they
would react in an infringing way. Not if they would react in
an infringing way where they have stated intentional malice.
It's if they would
>> and and actual
white hat white hat
slap lawsuit. Okay. With the best of intentions, he has filed
this lawsuit to ruin Casey. White hat financial
>> I dude Jesus Christ. >> He didn't go after everybody.
He only went out. >> That's my point that when he made
this
>> he wasn't thinking in terms of
I'm going to get XQC if he says this. I'm going to do Asold if
and you would probably agree this that his primary motivation
when he set the trap
they with me. I'm going to make something so delicious they have
to react to it. That's his words, not mine. You think when he
did that he was like these have it coming. They with me and now
I'm going to set a trap for them.
You think of that's plausible what I just described. >> That's
that's that might be a little bit of it, but but he really like
the whole idea of quote unquote setting a trap for people who
do it the worst way. Like I don't I don't think Casey, >> right?
But his definition of his definition of the worst way
wasn't stated intentional malice at that time when he said the
trap agreed, right? He couldn't have predicted >> Yes.
Okay. 100 things. It was the kind of we were seeing in the meta.
But the thing is that's even assuming that that was that his
motivation here is copyright which is absurd.
He's obviously using his prior experience with copyright and
his mantle as this copyright person as a cover to with them because
they with him. They with him. So now they get the pain and look
at how smart I was. I engineered this trap and when I get you
to apologize,
what is the apology he's actually looking for? Why isn't Ethan
saying this is a massive
>> Uh, hold on. Pumpern Nickel's here.
Yo, Pumpern Nickel, how's it going? >> Hey, how's it going?
How's my mic?
>> It's good. What's up?
>> Yeah, I was just listening to your stream and and and
thought you had an interesting take. Wanted to talk about
>> Yeah. So, I think Ethan's the clear goal of Ethan here
is to not protect his copyright, but to silence criticism.
>> Yeah, I I I think it can be both. I think um >> Okay,
but what do you think the ratio
I think Do you want me to propose a ratio first? Cuz I'm I'm
happy to go >> Sure. Sure. You go first. Yeah. >> So,
I think five out of six. So 56th of his reasoning for this is
drama and and silencing criticism and about one sixth is protecting
copyright his copyright.
>> Yeah. Like I I think all of us could admit that like
he's not under a lot of financial stress from the income he's
lost from Casey Tron's. >> Yeah. He he literally wasn't
tangibly harmed by Casey Tron in any way. >> I mean you're
right. But but I think disproportionately
leveraging your legal rights against people you hate more is
something that normal humans do every day all day all the time.
>> Yeah, maybe. Do normal humans do that? Would you do
that if you were Hold on. Would you do you think that would be
appropriate if you were in a space of like opinion columns and
you found out that you could sue somebody for something who writes
an opinion column and then you got you sued them for their opinion
column and your your settlement sorry you sue them for copyright
but then you also both write opinion columns and your settlement
in the copyright lawsuit is to for them to write an opinion column
saying you won and you're the best. >> You think that's
like a reasonable thing to do? opinion. So, because here's the
thing, I don't think he should be legally barred from doing any
of this, but in my opinion, he should be mocked for being the
biggest loser in the entire commentary space, bar none.
>> Sure, I get that. My understanding is that these kinds
of settlements, it's pretty common for them to have uh some kind
of uh when a person's giving an apology or something, that's
a pretty common clause in the end. >> In a copyright lawsuit,
it's normal to have an apology. Well, in in in essence in in
in effect of reducing the fee that the person is going to pay,
the person is like, I I can't pay this money that you're asking
for. I don't have it. >> Send me an example of a copyright
lawsuit where this has happened. >> Well, they apologize
for something totally unrelated to for where five six of the
apology is totally unrelated to copyright. They are they are
basically saying that the essence of their criticism and the
angle through which that they had that perspective of Ethan was
dishonest fundamentally from the beginning. They're just owning
up to their bias from the from the start.
>> Okay. And so talking about rising anti-semitism on the
left is is critical to why she approached the copyright.
>> He obviously will suggest that that's her motive. Um,
and if she come out and said, "Well, yeah, that is what we were
doing." I mean, I look, I don't believe Casey Tron was entirely
honest with with her statement and clear about her disgusting
her disgusting statements on Asmin Gold's mom. Why do you think
that was added? >> I think she's trying to get ahead of
another lawsuit for that.
>> Why would she be trying to get ahead of what Wait, what
could be the other lawsuit for that? >> Well, well, I don't
know. I I don't know the uh the uh legal rights that Asmin Gold
would have for for for that kind of behavior, but maybe maybe
she should >> somebody talking [__] You think
you think saying that as gold is responsible for respon you think
that's like uh that kind of talking is legally actionable? >> I
don't think so. But but I think I don't think that Casey Tron
right now is existing in a world where she can react to anything
based on what she perceives to be reality because that has been
shown to be entirely
like disjointed from what reality actually is. Like some people
have suggested that maybe um a lawyer wrote this statement for
Casey Troll or Ethan wrote it. I I listened to the video and
I thought maybe her family >> think like had look dug into
it and were like like
>> just just say say no to all of this. Disavow all of
it. Wind it down. >> Limit your exposure.
So, you think it was all just Casey Tron's opinion? Totally.
>> No, no, no. I think she's being pressured. Like, I don't
think her statement was like her real opinion at >> But
you think you think it was a pressured? So, why do you think
I believe they both both sides had to okay this? I believe that
has been talked about. Do I have that somewhere? I might have
that somewhere. One second. I think I got sent a link on this
where both sides did have to actually
Did they not both have to come to the same conclusion on this?
Like, they both had to agree to it? I mean, I guess just for
the fact that it's a settlement, they would have to agree to
it. But you think that her family came to her and were like,
"We really need you to more than anything actually talk about
how your statements about Asmin Gold's mom were really up." >> No.
Well, obviously clearly like Ethan can't include like statements
about Asmin Gold into this apology, right? That doesn't that
doesn't seem to be legally relevant. >> I don't know how
you could enforce that
>> because it's just a it's just a neutral contract between
two parties. Why would the law Why would connection. >> Sure.
Sure. Okay. Sure. He he could, right? But I don't believe that's
what he's done. And I don't understand where
>> win would be there for him for that particular
issue.
Like it's a very it's a very it's a pretty online niche comment
that she made about one guy. I don't know why that he would bring
that into his lawsuit over this whole thing. >> No, hold
on. Hold on, guys. She's saying uh Pumpern Nickel is saying that
she was pressured by her family, not Ethan Klein, to make this
state. >> I I feel like she is. I feel the way it read
to me is that she was. I can't obviously prove that. >> Okay.
All right. I think that is totally insane. And we have like a
lifetime of of Caseyron statements to go off of to say that that
is absolutely not the case. Like her entire online content career
has been being like a totally obstinate person.
>> Yeah. And now she's like totally changed. She's totally
like turned over a new leaf. She's completely different. I don't
know what I don't know under what pretext you could like have
this opinion. I think it's crazy personally. But again, I it's
just the vibes of the video. Like
>> I mean my wife told me to stop saying than I did. So
>> yeah, sure. Did your wife tell you to stop a logging
Kelly Jean and talking about how she's like lying about her
Oh yeah. No, no, no, she didn't. But I I >> Do you see
how that's like a totally different thing? Like actually your
your family members coming to you and being like, "Here's some
old internet drama that I'm aware of that you actually have to
go and apologize for apppropo of >> That's like totally
different, right? >> Do you really do you really think
I a logged Kelly June or is it just a funny >> I just remember
you fighting with her? It's like literally the one thing I remember
about like your general participation in the discourse is how
much you hated Kelly. This is like one thing I remembered. Honestly,
it's not a it's not a super relevant uh example
Yeah, it's true. I do hate Kelly.
>> Yeah, but like do you understand the example, right,
that I'm saying it's totally different for her to like go and
and bring up a totally different thing?
>> I I get it. What what I what I felt like when I was
watching her apology is that she was conceding
so much on things that weren't gerine to the court case,
the suit that she was involved in with Ethan. It felt like she
was apologizing for that suit and then she was trying to get
ahead
>> of some danger that she saw on the horizon potentially.
>> That's how I read it. >> All right, hold on. I
I know we could just we could just like we could just split the
world on this. Okay, so in the world where that statement was
primarily compelled by Ethan Klein that he gave her the points
he wanted her to make and that was like absolutely
required under him settling, you would just agree he's everything
I said, right? But in the world where Casey Tron mostly made
those statements entirely of her own valition, then I would agree
that I'm wrong. That that statement is wrong. Like I I would
say it's probably not right. Like if if if Casey Tron wasn't
suggested those topics or suggested any of those things, if she
just decided this is the stuff I have to say to avoid some future
lawsuit, then I would say, yeah, no, maybe Ethan maybe it's way
more related to copyright,
right? I think there's no shot on this entire planet of Earth.
But you'd have to agree with me that if Ethan did dictate most
of those things, he is everything I said and you would agree
entirely that this was like purely out of spite and and it was
totally up for him to do. He should be like the biggest loser.
He should be ostracized hard and feathered off the internet.
>> If Ethan dictated everything that she said in the apology,
including the the nonsequittor about apologizing about what she
said about Asen Gold and his mom
dictated that then yes, I would agree with you 100%.
>> Okay, perfect. All right. And when I say dictated, I
mean he has like a he has like a list of things that he probably
wanted. I don't think he would have written it. I think what
happened was he was saying, "You need to take back some of these
things, right?" And I think she would have written the statement
after being given the list of criteria that like she needed to
recant on or something and then her lawyers would have helped
her write the statement and they would have recorded it and then
sent it to Ethan. He would have approved it and then they would
have gone their merry way. I think that's likely the the way
it played out. >> Yeah. My my understanding from what I
managed to read this morning, I didn't read as much on it as
I would have liked to, is that Ethan, and correct me if I'm wrong,
Ethan
did did like he declined that he uh had anything to do with the
the apology, that he didn't mandate. >> He said he didn't
force her to lie, that it would be illegal for him to force her
to lie.
>> Right. Okay. >> That's way different, right? >> Okay.
So, he's Yeah, that's that's different for sure.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. So, that that's a different um
>> Yeah, that's different from what I what I heard that
he said. Yeah. >> Okay.
He said he approved it. I've still not seen this. Verain. If
somebody has an example of him saying that he approved it, >> I
believe that is true, >> but I don't not like he said he
saw it before she went live, but I don't know if that means she
sent a copy along to him or if he actually approved it. I agree.
It likely implies he improve approved it, but I don't think it
proves it categorically.
If if Ethan really
slide the >> slide the Asmin gold thing in there just for
like clout chasing I guess to to get the apology boosted more
on on social media and then I think that's
>> I mean okay so I think the difference between the two
of us is >> well I think he's making overures to Asmin
Gold and his community from a totally like >> from a totally
disingenuous like profit-seeking motive right that he is like
trying to ingratiate himself to Asmin Bish. >> Yes. Yeah.
So, I think you think it of that as unethical and I think of
it as incredibly cringe and lame.
But if she did do what she is alleged to have done or was was
uh found liable to have done and he had the right to do that
and to force her to tell the truth and she did tell the truth.
If all of those things are true, then I don't really have an
issue with what she said or the content of her apology. I think
it's kind of cringe if he brought Asmin into it just to like
make the apology go more viral. >> What about bringing
Hassan [__] into it? What if what if he asked for
Hassan [__] to be brought into it that she was going
to leave that alone, >> right? Yeah. >> Wouldn't
that be just as cringe? >> I think again cringe, but I
would I would I wouldn't go so far as to say
Um well I think it's sorry it's unethical when you make a habit
when your job has been criticizing and mocking people and and
like life ruination on the internet as a as a for like he has
been the person who goes and actually sh on people day after
day after day. Right. That's his whole thing. He is the biggest
bully in the yard. That's what he tries to do. That's what his
podcast has been for a long time. That's what a lot of his stuff
has been. Right. Right. But but she mocked people and then she
mocked him back >> and it was like, "Oh, now I have to
sue you for mocking me, >> but I'm going to sue you under
like you broke the law and now I'm going to try to ruin your
life in a very special unique way that by the way actually the
entire React space regardless of whether this goes to court now.
Now everything is for everybody. People just don't realize it
yet. Ethan Klein actually opened Pandora's box. It's over. Okay.
It's absolutely over.
>> You understand what I'm saying, right? I I get what
you're saying, but I feel like on someone. Um, >> wait,
what do you think I'm saying?
>> Sorry, I I was in my head with what what I was going
to say, so I glazed >> Oh, go ahead first and then I'll
go to it after. >> Yeah. Yeah. I was just going to say
that um I I feel like on someone for something that they did
or didn't do is entirely appropriate. If if Hassan went on stream
and he said he was gonna secretly like or implied that he was
going to secretly fund these people from behind the scenes or
whatever, I think it's within the realm of something Ethan might
want outlined in an apology that he didn't do that. He didn't
even reach out to these people and he wants these >> What
does that have to do with a violation of copyright law? >> It
it has nothing to do with that. And I think again it's cringe
and lame, but I don't think it's unethical if the the reason
that he's leveraged his right over this copyright law is because
of the like the interpersonal issues he has with these people.
And I feel like he doesn't admit that. He doesn't admit >> Of
course he doesn't. Of course he says that didn't happen. >> Of
course he doesn't. Because he's doing a copyright suit. He can't
say that the >> So when I say it's disingenuous, when I
say it's totally disingenuous, you agree
I mean, it's disingenuous in so far as what he presented to the
court, but I don't think it's disingenuous to the >> presented
publicly. >> I I take that. >> He said in his video
announcing the lawsuits that he was doing this to protect copyright.
>> He is transparently doing it like you agree with me.
You you agree he's transparently doing it to people who have
[__] with him personally. >> Yeah, that's that
that's cringe and lame if he said that. I I think you but I think
you can have it both ways. I think he could have said it's I'm
doing it for copyright, whatever. um or at least I hate these
people and the way that I'm attacking them is through copyright.
And that's kind of how I read that video that he released where
he was um memeing on the trap that he had set. I thought it was
pretty obvious that it was a copyright trap that they had walked
into with that video that they all streamed.
Like I I thought it was I thought it was pretty plain that he
was doing that. I thought it was kind of the in the inference
for everybody and that did nothing to diminish his legal rights
to that claim.
>> No, I don't think he I don't think he loses any of his
legal rights.
I think he could totally pursue this. The thing is is he's now
unlocked essentially and publicized a tool people can use to
silence criticism of basically anybody, anytime, anywhere in
the current streaming format, right? So people will now have
to go do all of this like editing down of videos. still have
to pre-watch like the reaction meta is dead. So the thing he
said he wasn't going after actually he's totally gone after it.
He is
>> right. I mean I mean he specifically literally any full
video that XQC just to be clear any full video that XQC or Asthma
would react to now those people if it's from the past like two
to three months those people can go file a patent with the Library
of Congress or a copyright with the Library of Congress and then
they can sue those people and collect statutory damages.
Right. But there's still the exception for like transformative
content, right? Like these people literally say, >> "No,
no, there." Trust me. So basically, all conventional wisdom says
that if you're reacting to a video in full, without pre-watching
it in any way, without time stamps, without anything, that will
never ever pass muster for fair use. There's no amount of transformation
that will actually pass fair use. We live in a gray zone right
now where that's never been established. But that was implied
heavily by the Matt Hos lawsuit that like basically they're saying
you can use pieces but and when you do so with intention it obviously
is fair use right but you know the more of the work you use the
less likely you are to have a fair use transformative work and
using the full video recording recording your reaction to the
full video is very very very unlikely to ever be considered fair
use. Not impossible but unlikely.
>> Sure. Like if you play a full video, the extra transformative
content that you're going to need to add onto that to qualify
for transformative content is going to be larger than if you
just use clips of it. I think that's a given I think with >> case
but but basically so he said I don't want to target XQC because
he did a good faith react. This will XQC's current business model.
Yes. >> I I don't think so.
Why? I I I think if you watch a whole video and you are in the
chair and you're watching it and you're pausing, you're commented,
you giving your opinion on what someone just said in the >> Do
you believe denims will win in court? >> I don't know with
denims.
>> So denims did a significantly more transformative, more
critical, more aware
than XC did. >> Well, I mean definitely more. >> No,
you you just said you don't think of XC's business model who
basically just sits there silently while videos play AND HE GOES,
"WHAT? THAT'S COOKED CHAT. >> HEY, if if uh if >> nearly
nothing. Okay. Sure.
>> The issue with this, I think, is that you'll get down
to like, well,
how do you measure the quality of transformative content? Um,
like with with XQC, like I don't watch his content. Never interesting
to me. Uh, I wouldn't consider it transformative. I'm
bamboozled
that he has not already been sued by um like way bigger publications
or or or producers like did >> because everybody on the
internet shows and stuff. >> Like it blows my mind that
that that's >> Well, I can I can explain it to you. >> Right.
The way all people work on the internet right now, one I don't
think XQC does a lot of I think he did Hell's Kitchen the last
time and I think basically everybody uses the tool that's there
which is the DMCA claim. Okay. If you don't want to use the DMCA
claim, there is one other tool you can use. It's it's attempting
to get these statutory damages that apply when you register through
the Library of Congress, right? But no online content creator
does that. Basically, none of them, right? They just use the
DMCA service that's available through YouTube. Ethan Klein decided
not to do that. He didn't want to DMCA anything. He just went
for this other path that would allow him to sue immediately without
any notice at all. Right. >> Well, sure. He But he was
trying to set >> He was trying to set a precedent with
this though, wasn't he? >> What's the precedent he's trying
to set? because he set a precedent and it's totally the reaction
game and everything he said he was trying to protect. It's totally
dead in the water. It is dead. Okay. The only thing that exists
now is the glaze reacts. All critical reactions are now a huge
risk for everybody. A massive liability.
>> You cannot be critical and react to somebody's video.
>> It's It's not just surely. Okay. So, do you think Casey
Trump was just critical or do you think she was dishonest?
I don't think she was anything. I think she probably smoked weed
and farted the whole time.
>> Okay. But like there's a difference. >> You think
she was dishonest? Guess what? If you think she was lying about
Ethan Klein, there's a different thing you do there, isn't there?
You know what it is,
>> Sure. But if >> Sure. But no, what is it? What
is it? What do you do if somebody's lying about >> Well,
you can go for a defamation suit, >> Oh, it's like a totally
different legal process. It's a complaint for litigating what
he thinks is a defamation claim, what he perceives is a defamation
claim through copyright. >> But people go after whatever
they think is most likely to work all the time in legal proceedings,
not necessarily what actually happened. Like the police do this.
If they can't get someone on one crime, they will downgrade
them on something else. >> Do they extract a statement
that can be used ostensibly in the way that an apology for a
defamation lawsuit would be used? And and if you're doing so,
then I'm going to call you a disingenuous, spineless.
Okay, that's what I'm going to do. And I think it's incumbent
on every single commenter on the internet to do the same because
otherwise there will no longer be criticism. There will no longer
it's going to go by the wayside. Okay? Or at least it's going
to be significantly harder. Like way way way harder.
>> If you want to suck Ethan off, you get full video reacts.
You could be Casey Tron if you suck him off. Okay? You could
be some fat losser who just watches full streams. He won't give
a But if you if you say he sucks. If you say that he didn't take
care of his dogs, oh boy, you're evil and you're going to get
[__] Dude,
they didn't just say that though, right?
>> What did What did Casey say? Go ahead. >> Well,
I mean, the whole H3H3 snark community was more than just saying,
"Hey, Ethan sucks." >> What part of Caseyron or what part
of Caseyron uh Caseron stream or content is H3H3 Snark? Please
do not web Caseyron to H3 Stark in the same way that Destiny
webs me to Kiwi Farms. Please don't do that on my stream. It's
extremely like upsetting, off-putting, weird. Okay, don't do
that.
>> Wait, I thought that's what it literally was though.
Like unironically, I thought I thought that's literally the relationship.
Like like Frogo, >> she might. But I'm saying you need
to tell me what it is. >> If you understand that if you
can't explain what it is, you've just gone on hearsay. It feels
really weird for you to come on and argue it, right? >> She
might have. I don't know. She might open up H3 Stark every day
on her stream and go, "I'm going to read I'm going to read every
single post about cheddar." Well, eating cheddar. Okay. >> I'm
I'm saying I'm saying I don't know. >> I'm I'm saying it's
my belief that Ethan clearly thought that.
>> So, okay. Well, it's my belief that Trump thought he
actually was was out of the election in 20 in 2020 and he had
every right to go and try to steal it, >> Yeah. Yeah. And
unfortunately, >> we should entertain the the delusions
of totally psychotic losers. >> Yo, he won election, so
I guess that was
>> Okay, now you're just meing. All right.
>> I understand you're like a little inebriated. It's okay.
>> No, no, but seriously though, like I I honestly thought
that that's that's what her position was, that she she was part
of that anti-fan community. And look, I don't care about Casey
or Ethan that much. Um, >> and Ethan maybe
Ethan may well have been using the copyright claims in order
to target. >> Do you think that being a part of that anti-fan
community means you should have your life destroyed or your pride
destroyed? Like basically you have to do you have to dance around
in circles and say you're a little piggy until I'm satisfied
and then I will settle this lawsuit because I'm rich and you're
poor and I can hire lawyers and you over. So dance around and
say you're a little piggy and then I'll let you go little piggy.
You think that's an appropriate way to live life? I would be
incredibly upset if it happened to me, but unironically if I
I I mean I go out of my way to not make enemies with people that
could >> I'm not even saying that you I'm not even saying
that Casey Tron didn't around and figure out. I'm saying the
person who did it is a disgusting
loser and you should agree. You should obviously agree
Yeah, I think you kind of convinced me a little bit.
Okay, thank you.
Uh yeah, if that's what happened, then yeah, I I I I guess I
would concede that um now I I will say that I am going off the
vibes of that video that I think it's very very very clear that
she is being compelled to make that statement. If for some reason
Ethan gave her zero notes and didn't have to approve that and
basically the only condition of this was that she provided an
apology um without any details at all. If that's the case, then
oh my god. I I think I would have to re-evaluate how I see
>> Yeah. If if if Ethan has it the the
>> what the do you call it? The u the not the golden bullet,
the silver gun. What the [__] is it? The expression
silver bullet. the Yeah, that if if um if Ethan really like hedged
that like Asmin Gold comment in there, if he put that into the
script, >> then I would go from like
your way or the Hassan comment >> or the comments about
Lena and it's just extracting like drama in a copyright. It has
nothing to do with the actual legal violation. If he put those
in there and he he made her say those legally through whatever
mechanism
um then yeah, I would
significantly more towards your interpretation of things. I felt
like watching that video that either her family, her legal team
around her has looked into this issue and just the totality of
everything that was around the lawsuit has found potential possible
legal exposure in the future from other interactions and was
trying to get ahead of the game and and make those clarifications.
That's what I felt like watching it.
>> Okay. I just don't understand what so if anything those
clarification you understand if anything those clarifications
when she says she does those things disingenuously and she should
know better you understand that those would if anything open
her up right she's she's expressing her mental state in a statement
>> you understand that if anything that would open her
up
but if they're operating on a premise that people sue people
in in court for these things based on emotional responses like
you alleging that Ethan just did then I could imagine how that
might be considered a legitimate
>> Okay. All right. >> Like if it's what they think
Ethan just did, right? Or what you think Ethan just did. So why
wouldn't they be like, "What if Asmin Gold does that, too? We'll
we'll try to to modify him."
>> I I guess so. Yeah. Hope. Please don't >> It makes
sense. It makes sense, but like I don't know if it's true or
not,
Um, I don't think it makes sense. I think it's I think it's basically
giving Asenold the totally like gate my button and going like
I know I said all those things about you. Here's the button.
Please show mercy sir. Now I me personally I don't think I don't
believe in that kind of action. Okay. Please don't rate my app
with this button I've given you, sir. I just don't think that's
possible. I I that would be totally insane for Casey trying to
do that to go to Asmin Gold and say I know all the things I said
about you. I know we've had our tussles over the years. here's
like everything you need to totally [__] me over.
Please don't.
I
I I don't want to talk about the law too much because I know
nothing about it, but I I could imagine a scenario where preempting
a lawsuit, making a statement about how, no, I lied about this
person. It's not true. That was an outrageous lie. Don't listen
to that. I disavow it. would actually
come into mitigation when it comes to liabilities in a future.
>> No, I could see that. I could I can see that coming
to the perspective. >> You've admitted guilt hoping without
any like without any contact with the other side. I don't believe
that a uh lawyer would do that. But you So you've admitted guilt
but said I hope that this reduces damages.
>> Maybe that could be the case. I doubt a lawyer would
say admit guilt first before talking to the to the other party.
It depends on how I guess
they think she is. And and my my perception of Casey Tron is
is that she she was pretty like damned to rights on this whole
issue and it was always going to end this way. >> She I
mean she definitely has been a total copyright thief for a long
time.
That way. >> Yeah. You you you've nudged me from like uh
60% 40% to more like 8020 I think.
>> Okay. 80 20 what? Just to be >> Ethan's a piece
of
>> Oh, nice. Okay, cool.
>> I still have 20 because I think that you know I mean
all the >> I mean I would admit that if Casey Tron just
did this if if she had no notes. Now the thing is man I don't
know if you could convince me that she had no show that she had
no notes. I actually don't know if you could convince me of this
in any possible way that she wasn't told here are the things
we want.
>> I I literally don't know, man. >> It was definitely
written. I just like I just think it may have been written by
someone else like not necessarily
Ethan if if she's the direction I feel
>> I feel like the directions would have come through Ethan's
lawyer or Ethan himself, right? and Ethan's lawyer were saying
Ethan himself basically but through the lawyer like there would
have been hey these are the things we'd like concessions on and
you could write it how you need to write it but we need these
concessions.
>> Sure. I'm just saying that I I I wouldn't be surprised
if her legal team or whoever is close to her sprinkled some some
um hundreds and thousands
on the top of this uh
apology just to
cut off future liability potentially.
>> Again, I really feel like they actually >> it's
anything if that were the case they added to future liability
unfortunately. >> But maybe Yeah. Yeah. Maybe I I would
like I I mean I would like to live in a world where confessing
that you lied about someone or you said something that wasn't
true would limit your liability
because
I feel like that's happen but >> limit damages like but
because from from my understanding with a lot of defamation basically
the first step to defamation is hey that's a lie. I'm not sure
I'm aware I'm not sure you're aware if that was a lie but that
was a lie and you shouldn't do that. And here I'm I'm telling
you you have to retract you have to recant that lie or we're
going to see you in court. Right. >> So it's possible that
she her recanting it immediately might help. But when she says
her mental state, which I forget what it was, like the misogyny
thing, I forget exactly what it was. I think the misogyny thing
was with the Ethan. I forget what her rationale was with as gold,
but if she admitted to like a bad mental state, it's possible
that she
it's possible that she
like admitted to the crime and and it might not matter that she
recanted cuz she admitted to basically doing it totally disingenuously
just to harm the other person.
>> Yeah, sure. I I don't know enough about the technicalities
of the law to to know. It was just >> I really don't either.
It's fine.
>> Yeah. Anyway, that was my take.
>> Sounds good, man. All right. All right. Well, thanks
for coming on. Yeah. Love the stream. Appreciate it. Take care.
Bye-bye. Take care. Bye.